.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Gut machst du das,
mit den Beinchen strampeln.
Die kleine Valeria leidet unter
einem extrem seltenen Gendefekt.
Sie kann sich nicht bewegen
und hat täglich
unzählige epileptische Anfälle.
Eine Behandlung gibt es nicht.
Ist schon wieder vorbei.
Ihre Eltern haben
in einer weltweiten Recherche
ein Team von Wissenschaftlern
gefunden,
die ein Medikament für die
Anderthalbjährige entwickeln wollen.
Das kostet aber 2 Mio. Fr.
Mit
einer grossangelegten Spendenaktion
versuchen sie, das Geld aufzutreiben.
Normalerweise
sterben diese Kinder früh.
Darum
ist es ein Wettlauf gegen die Zeit.
Unsere Erdbeere.
Kannst du mir helfen,
das Tuch über sie zu legen?
Valeria ist das erste Kind
von Mario und Alexandra Schenkel.
Kurz nach ihrer Geburt merkten sie,
dass etwas nicht stimmt.
Man weiss nicht,
was normal ist und was nicht.
Aber als sie nicht mehr atmete ...
Das ist ja logisch. Das ist ...
Da wussten wir,
dass etwas nicht stimmte
und wir mit ihr ins Spital mussten.
Was das Ganze mit sich bringt,
konnten wir in dem Moment
aber nicht abschätzen.
Es dauerte Wochen,
bis die Ärzte die Ursache fanden.
Das Ergebnis: Valeria leidet
an einer Mutation auf dem KCNT1-Gen.
Die Nervenzellen in ihrem Gehirn
arbeiten nicht richtig zusammen.
Deshalb ist ihre motorische
und kognitive Entwicklung
stark beeinträchtigt.
Weltweit
gibt es nicht einmal 100 Kinder,
die
an dieser Form des Gendefekts leiden.
Im Moment müssen wir froh sein,
dass sie selber atmet
und selber isst.
Wir sehen oft, dass andere Kinder
Magensonden haben,
beatmet werden
und die ganze Zeit im Spital sind.
Ich muss immer Holz anfassen,
wenn ich das erzähle.
Wir müssen froh darüber sein,
wie es ihr geht.
Sie wäre einfach schwerstbehindert.
Das ist nicht vielleicht so,
das ist sicher so.
Wenn wir nichts machen.
Hm? Aber darum machen wir etwas.
- Mhm.
Mai 2019.
Als Erstes müssen
die Eltern das Geld auftreiben.
An ihrem Wohnort bei Luzern
starten sie heute
eine Sammelkampagne.
1 Mio. Fr. kommt aus ihrem Ersparten,
von Verwandten und Freunden.
Doch für die zweite Million
brauchen sie Hilfe.
Der Startschuss
ist ein Benefizkonzert.
Ich hoffe, dass wir 100'000 Fr.
zusammenbekommen.
Es gibt auch noch
die Luftballonaktionen
am Samstag in der Stadt.
Es sind etwa 50 Leute,
die uns helfen.
Oder noch mehr.
Ich habe nie gezählt.
Es sind 14 Stände.
Das sind mehr als 50 Leute.
Es ist grossartig,
wie sie uns alle unterstützen.
Einer ihrer Freunde hat die Luzerner
Band Dada Ante Portas angefragt,
ob sie bereit wären, ein Konzert
zugunsten von Valeria zu geben.
Es kommen immer wieder
solche Benefizanfragen rein.
Diese hat uns alle berührt.
Das war der Grund,
weshalb wir zusagten.
Wenn es uns berührt, kümmert es uns,
und dann wollen wir
das auch unterstützen.
Das Konzert
stösst auf grosses Interesse.
Die 250 Eintritte waren sofort weg.
Jeder gibt, soviel er will oder kann.
Ich hoffe, diese traurige Geschichte
hat ein Happy End.- Danke.
Sie sammeln aber
nicht nur hier am Konzert.
Sie konnten die Medien dazu bringen,
breit über Valeria zu berichten.
Auf einer Crowdfunding-Seite
sind so in den ersten 24 Std.
schon über 300'000 Fr.
zusammengekommen.
Ihre Unterstützung, Ihre Spenden
fliessen in die Valeria Association.
Und ...
Sie merken: Ich bin sprachlos.
Wir haben heute
schon einen grossen Schritt gemacht.
Mit dem heutigen Abend
werden wir noch viel weiterkommen.
Dafür ganz herzlichen Dank.
Alexandra und ich möchten euch
ein kleines Geschenk überreichen,
damit ihr immer an Valeria denkt.
Wir hoffen ganz fest,
dass sie sich eines Tages
für euren Einsatz
bei euch bedanken kann.- Genau.
Das ist mal ...
* Applaus *
* Lockere Musik *
Während des Konzerts
kümmern sich die Organisatoren
im Hintergrund um die Spendenkassen.
Einer meiner Freunde ist Taxifahrer.
Er hatte eine Sammelbox für Valeria,
die ihm aus dem Auto geklaut wurde.
Jetzt haben wir Angst, dass wir
das Geld wegbringen sollten.
Denn:
Es ist einiges zusammengekommen.
Gut, super.
- Juhu!
Alexandra bringt das Geld
noch in der Nacht zur Bank.
Am Konzert
sammeln sie fast 13'000 Fr.
Ein stolzer Betrag
und ein guter Anfang.
Aber bis zur Million
ist es noch ein weiter Weg.
Es ist eine riesige Hürde.
Aber wenn wir die geschafft haben
und das Thema beiseitelegen können,
ist das eine grosse Entlastung.
Dann können wir uns umso mehr
auf Valeria und ihre Therapie
konzentrieren.
Du hast es gut gemacht Schatz.
Wie geht's der kleinen Maus?
Wahrscheinlich schläft sie jetzt.
- Gut.
Die Sammelaktion
geht am Wochenende weiter.
50 Freiwillige,
darunter auch Valerias Grosseltern,
bauen zwischen Luzern und Zürich
Stände auf.
Doch ist es nicht unangenehm,
fremde Menschen um Geld zu bitten?
Man muss vielleicht
eine Hemmschwelle überschreiten.
Wenn man sich
aber den Gesamtkontext ansieht,
versteht man das und es ist
kein Betteln im eigentlichen Sinn,
sondern ein Teilnehmen
an Valerias Schicksal.
Es ist ein Thema, das motiviert.
Ein gemeinsames Ziel,
eine sinnvolle Aufgabe.
Und es lohnt sich,
sich dafür zu engagieren.
Mario Schenkel ist Rechtsanwalt
mit eigener Kanzlei in Luzern.
Die Spendensumme ist über Nacht
auf über 420'000 Fr. gestiegen.
Es ist bis heute europaweit
das erfolgreichste Crowdfunding
im Bereich Medizin.
Eigentlich haben wir
noch nicht einmal die Hälfte.
Aber es ist erst ein Tag.
Das muss man auch bedenken.
So etwas gab es noch nie.
Das ist megacool.
Besser hätte man das
nicht machen können.
Doch wieso müssen die Eltern
die Entwicklung des Medikaments
überhaupt selber bezahlen?
Wären dafür nicht die Krankenkasse
oder die IV zuständig?
Es ist kein anerkanntes Medikament,
deshalb wird es nicht finanziert -
weder von der IV
noch von der Krankenkasse.
In der Schweiz ist es leider so,
dass weder IV noch Krankenkasse
etwas an die Entwicklungskosten
eines Medikamentes zahlen.
Kommt dazu,
dass ihnen auch die Wissenschaftler
der Harvard Medical School in Amerika
nicht versprechen können, ob und wie
das Medikament wirken wird.
Die Hoffnungen sind aber gross.
Man geht davon aus, dass sie
keine Krämpfe mehr haben wird
und sich entwickeln kann - bis sogar
zu einem gesunden Menschen.
Aber von keine Krämpfe
und sich entwickeln können
bis zu ganz normal sein, ist
natürlich eine grosse Spannbreite.
Es kann uns niemand sagen,
bis wohin sie kommt.
Gerade
die epileptischen Krampfanfälle
quälen Valeria 30-, 40-mal am Tag.
* Valeria weint. *
Gegen die Krämpfe hilft CBD-Öl.
Es lindert die Symptome.
Das Medikament
soll die Grunderkrankung heilen.
Das Ärzte- und Forscherteam
in den USA ist überzeugt,
dass es helfen wird.
Bei einem anderen Kind
mit einem ähnlichen Gendefekt
hat es funktioniert.
Eine Garantie gibt es nicht.
Aber ... Wie soll ich sagen?
Sie haben keinen plausiblen Grund,
wieso es nicht funktionieren sollte.
Wenn es einmal funktioniert ...
... funktioniert es
beim anderen Gen auch.
Voller Hoffnung fliegt Mario Schenkel
am nächsten Tag nach Holland.
Er hat in Leiden ein Labor gefunden,
das die ersten Prototypen
von Valerias Medikament testet.
Ich habe euch etwas mitgebracht.
Das ist für dich und dein Team.
Es ist schwer.
Wir haben es selber gemacht.
Danke.
Vielen Dank für alles, was ihr für
Valeria macht und für eure Hilfe.
Mario Schenkel ist zwar kein Arzt,
hat inzwischen aber sehr viel gelernt
über den äusserst seltenen Gendefekt
und die mögliche Behandlung.
Das Prinzip: Sog. Oligos
binden sich an das defekte Gen
und schalten es aus.
So könnte die Reizübertragung
in Valerias Gehirn
wieder mehr
oder weniger normal funktionieren.
Ich überlege immer, welches
der schnellste Weg sein könnte,
um zum Ziel zu kommen.
Es ist kompliziert.
Ich habe keine Ahnung,
aber sie erklären mir immer alles,
und machen Zeichnungen usw.
Die nächste Zeichnung
ist frustrierend: der Zeitplan.
Jetzt sind wir hier.
Dann kommen zwei weitere Runden?
Zuerst hiess es Oktober,
es könnte aber auch früher sein.
Es kommt immer wieder etwas dazu,
das man noch besser machen könnte.
Das ist gut.
Wir haben viele gute Teile.
Und ...
Ja ...
Die besten dieser Teile aus Amerika
lässt Mario im Labor untersuchen.
Die Firma
ist spezialisiert auf solche Tests.
Wie gross schätzt der Wissenschaftler
die Chance ein,
dass sie wirklich
ein passendes Oligo finden werden?
Es ist sehr schwierig vorauszusagen,
ob wir etwas finden werden,
das Valeria hilft.
Ich glaube,
dass wir etwas finden werden,
das Valerias mutiertes Gen
verändern kann.
Aber ich weiss nicht,
ob wir es soweit verändern können,
dass es eine Wirkung hat.
Aber es gibt keine Alternative.
Ich habe volles Verständnis.
Sie wollen nur das Beste machen.
Bei ... Bei ...
Also, volles Verständnis: Ich drehe
einfach nicht völlig durch.
Ich kann ja nicht.
Sie sind die einzige Chance.
Im Moment
kumulieren sich seine Probleme:
Alles braucht mehr Zeit
und kostet viel mehr Geld
als ursprünglich geplant.
Zurück in der Kanzlei in Luzern.
Die Eltern
haben alle Experten selber gefunden
und sie miteinander vernetzt.
Mario steht täglich in Kontakt
mit den verschiedenen Labors
und v.a.
dem Neurogenetiker in Boston.
Es geht ihm alles viel zu langsam.
Wir können ja nicht sagen ...
... sie sollen
endlich vorwärtsmachen.
Wir müssen immer
die richtigen Worte finden.
In unseren Augen passiert
lange eigentlich nichts,
aber sie arbeiten alle daran.
Wir sind ja nicht im Labor
und schauen,
was sie machen
und wie lange es dauert.
Es braucht viel Vertrauen
in die Leute, und das haben wir.
Und ständig tauchen Zusatzkosten auf,
die die ganze Kalkulation
wieder über den Haufen werfen.
Weil sie jetzt in Australien
und Yale noch Tests machen,
die wir auch finanzieren müssen,
kommt immer mehr dazu.
Was am Anfang unterging:
der Spitalaufenthalt
am Boston Children's Hospital,
in dem
das Medikament verabreicht wird.
Dafür haben sie
400'000 Fr. veranschlagt.
Bei den Finanzen
gibt's aber auch gute Nachrichten.
Die ursprünglich anvisierte Million
ist nach nur drei Tagen beisammen.
Plötzlich
kriegten wir eine riesige Spende
und machten einen grossen Sprung.
Dann entwickelte das eine Dynamik.
Um 18, 18.30 Uhr
war das Geld beisammen.
Einer dieser Grossspender
ist bei der heutigen Sammelaktion vor
dem Luzerner Fussballstadion dabei.
Wir sind selber
in der Versicherungsbranche tätig.
Als wir hörten,
dass Entwicklungskosten
nicht bezahlt werden,
fanden wir,
dass es uns doppelt betrifft.
Auch andere Firmen engagieren sich.
Eine Luzerner Bäckerei
spendet 1'000 Schachteln Pralinen.
Die verkaufen sie
vor einem Fussballspiel
des FC Luzern an die Besucher.
Mario Schenkel ist Fussball wichtig.
Er war schon immer Fan des FCL.
Er ist nicht mehr
so wichtig wie vorher.
Wir gehen seit ein paar Jahren
immer zusammen an die Matches.
Bei diesem Spiel will er schweizweit
auf die Sammelaktion
aufmerksam machen.
Haltet euch überall fest
und wackelt etwas.
Hochhalten.
Versucht, es schön zu spannen.
Mit der Fussballaktion
steigt das Spendentotal
um weitere 50'000 Fr. an.
Ist alles gut? Oben halten.
- (Durchsage) Nummer 34, Silvan.
Vielen Dank. Supergeil.
- Nummer 42, Idris.
September 2019.
Morgen fliegen Schenkels nach Boston.
Abschied von den Nachbarn.
Wir melden dann mal, wie es läuft.
- Ist gut.
Über WhatsApp und so. Danke.
- Klar.
Wann Valeria ihr Medikament
im Boston Children's Hospital
zum ersten Mal bekommen wird,
ist aber immer noch unklar.
Jetzt sieht es nach Oktober aus.
Wir dachten,
es sei ein schlechtes Zeichen,
wenn wir sagen,
wir würden unseren Flug verschieben.
Vor Ort ist immer besser.
Wenn man persönlich
mit ihnen spricht.
Dann merkt man auch,
ob wirklich alles gut ist
und wie lange es gehen wird.
Sie wissen dann, dass wir da sind.
* Valeria weint. *
Auch Valeria scheint zu spüren,
dass etwas passiert.
In den letzten Wochen weint sie oft
und lässt sich fast nicht beruhigen.
Die letzten drei Wochen
waren neben allem anderen,
was sonst noch war,
sehr kräfteraubend.
Weil man sieht,
dass es ihr nicht so gutgeht.
Darum müssen wir es jetzt
noch etwas aushalten.
Wir sind froh,
dass wir gehen können und wissen,
dass sie etwas kriegt,
von dem wir ausgehen,
dass es ihr
nachher viel besser geht.
Zuversichtlich stimmt sie,
dass Valeria kürzlich einen
kleinen Entwicklungsschub hatte.
Das war, als es Valeria gut ging.
* Fröhliche Musik
aus "Arielle, die Meerjungfrau" *
Tanzt du etwas, Schatz?
* Lachen *
Valeria kann durchaus zeigen,
wenn sie glücklich ist:
Ihre Augen strahlen
und sie zappelt mit den Beinchen.
Dass es höchstwahrscheinlich
viel besser sein wird als jetzt ...
... davon kann man wohl ausgehen.
Aber ob ein Wunder passiert ...
Sie sagen,
es könne auch ein Wunder passieren.
Wenn man einer Maus,
die diesen Gendefekt hat,
dieses Medikament gibt,
dann passiert ein Wunder.
Sie
wird zu einer ganz normalen Maus.
Und du bist auch eine kleine Maus.
Bei dir ist das dann auch so.
Hoffentlich.
- Mhm.
Ein halbes Jahr später -
inzwischen ist es März 2020.
Über die Welt
bricht das Coronavirus herein.
In Boston wartet Familie Schenkel
seit einem halben Jahr
auf den Beginn der Behandlung.
Der Kleinen
geht es auch wieder etwas besser.
Vor einer Woche hatte sie Tage,
an denen sie nur geschrien hat.
Aber jetzt
ist es zum Glück wieder besser.
Hier in den USA
geht es uns eigentlich auch gut.
Uns belastet,
dass es nicht so vorwärtsgeht
mit dem Medikament für die Kleine,
wie wir es uns erhofft hatten.
Mäuschen.
Im Februar feiert Valeria
ihren zweiten Geburtstag.
Es könnte ihr letzter gewesen sein.
- Mmh.
Bravo.
Betrachtet man die durchschnittliche
Lebenserwartung dieser Kinder,
hat Valeria
zwei Drittel ihres Lebens gelebt.
Mhm.
- Ja.
Aber ...
Ich gehe immer davon aus,
dass es ihr besser gehen wird.
Ja, es geht ihr megagut.
- Momentan.
Das würde nicht von einem Tag
auf den anderen passieren.
Das weiss man leider nicht.
Es könnte eine Infektion oder so
sein, die ihr Immunsystem schwächt.
Trotzdem
läuft Valeria die Zeit davon.
Haben sie nie ans Aufgeben gedacht?
Und glauben sie noch daran,
dass der Neurowissenschaftler
wirklich ein taugliches Medikament
entwickeln kann?- Ich lass dich los.
Die Leute wollen ja Erfolg
mit dem haben, was sie machen.
Sie wollen
nur das Beste für Valeria.
Solange es die Option gibt,
ist für uns klar:
Wir bleiben dran.
Das ist im Moment der Weg,
den wir für Valeria
und als Familie gehen.
Lichtblicke
sind die Besuche aus der Schweiz.
Mario und sein Vater probieren
Grossvaters neue Drohne aus.
Schenkels leben in einer Kleinstadt
in der Nähe
des Boston Children's Hospital.
Wie lange sie hierbleiben müssen,
wissen sie nicht.
Doch wovon leben sie eigentlich?
Mario ist Partner
in der Anwaltskanzlei in Luzern
und kann von Boston aus arbeiten.
Ich habe reduziert gearbeitet.
Wir haben einen Lohn bekommen,
aber wir waren auch sparsam.
Während Corona
konnten wir ja auch nichts machen.
Wir gingen mit Valeria
in all die Therapien -
und leider auch oft ins Spital.
Sonst haben wir kein Geld gebraucht.
Tschau, mein Mädchen.
Tschau, tschau.
Endlich - heute ist der grosse Tag:
Nach einem Jahr in Boston
bekommt das Medikament die Zulassung
der Arzneimittelbehörde FDA
und Valeria
ihre erste Dosis Valeriasen.
So heisst das Medikament.
Es muss ihr in Vollnarkose
ins Rückenmark gespritzt werden,
damit es im Gehirn
das fehlerhafte Gen abdecken kann.
Parallel dazu
werden Valerias Hirnströme überwacht.
Der Neurogenetiker Timothy Yu,
der das Medikament entwickelt hat,
begleitet die Behandlung
auf Schritt und Tritt.
Beim ersten Mal bekommt sie
nur eine ganz kleine Dosis.
Dann alle zwei Wochen etwas mehr.
Sie scheint Valeriasen
gut zu vertragen.
Die Veränderung ist offensichtlich.
- Super.
Die inzwischen Dreijährige
reagiert stärker auf ihre Umwelt,
nimmt wahr,
was um sie herum passiert,
hat deutlich weniger Krampfanfälle.
- Ja, du bist so gut.
Sie blüht richtig auf,
trainiert ihre Muskeln.
Und eine weitere gute Nachricht:
Valeria wird im Sommer
ein Geschwisterchen bekommen.
Trotz 24-Std.-Betreuung,
auch durch die Grosseltern
aus der Schweiz,
verschlechtert sich
Valerias Zustand wieder.
Ein Jahr nach Beginn der Behandlung
erreicht uns im September 2021
die Nachricht,
vor der sich alle gefürchtet haben:
Valeria ist gestorben.
* Nachdenkliche Klänge *
Wir hofften immer,
wir seien genug schnell,
um ihr helfen zu können.
Ja. Wir haben ihr ...
- Ich ... Ja.
Wir haben alles gemacht,
damit es möglichst schnell ging.
Es hätte
keinen schnelleren Weg gegeben,
um Valeria zu helfen.
Die Hoffnung war riesig
und blieb bis am Schluss.
Wir haben sie nie verloren,
obwohl der Weg sehr steinig war.
Was hat schlussendlich
zu Valerias Tod geführt?
Es hat sich über längere Zeit
Hirnflüssigkeit
in ihrem Kopf angesammelt.
Man hat das viel zu spät entdeckt.
Also ja. Dass ...
Ich kann nicht viel dazu sagen,
ich bin ja kein Arzt.
Ich weiss nicht ...
Man muss davon ausgehen, dass es
ein Nebeneffekt des Medikaments war.
Von diesem Oligo. Aber ...
Es ist nicht so,
dass es nicht sicher ist.
Man hat ihr einfach zu viel gegeben,
höchstwahrscheinlich.
Die genaue Todesursache
wird noch untersucht.
Dass es zu einer
so dramatischen Entwicklung kam,
hat alle überrascht.
Auch den Neurogenetiker Timothy Yu.
Hätte er
nicht früher erkennen müssen,
dass etwas nicht stimmt mit Valeria?
Man hätte es
sicher früher merken können.- Ja.
Nicht er ...
... selber.
Da war ein ganzes Ärzteteam ...
... involviert.
Er war nicht Neurologe
und behandelnder Arzt.
Aber man hätte es merken können.
- Wir haben den Eindruck ...
... dass es ziemlich schnell
erste Anzeichen gab,
bei denen man
im Nachhinein denkt ...
... man hätte allenfalls ...
... genauer hinsehen oder es auf
eine andere Art untersuchen müssen.
Ja.
Timothy Yu
darf uns kein Interview geben.
Das Spital hat es ihm verboten.
Heute treffen ihn Schenkels
zu einem Abschiedsgespräch.
In ein paar Tagen
fliegen sie zurück in die Schweiz.
Ganz wird der Kontakt
aber nicht abreissen.
Timothy Yus Labor und andere
Institutionen, auch in Europa,
werden weiter
an Valeriasen arbeiten,
denn das Medikament
hat durchaus Potential.
Im ersten halben Jahr der Behandlung
ging es Valeria nämlich so gut,
dass sie wie alle Kinder
an ihrem dritten Geburtstag
in den lokalen Kindergarten kam.
Die sog. Preschool
hat eine Klasse für Kinder
mit speziellen Bedürfnissen.
Hi, Michelle.
- Schön, dich zu sehen.
Wie viele Kinder
sind in einer Klasse?- Es sind 12.
Alle Kinder, ob gesund
oder mit Beeinträchtigungen,
haben in Boston Anrecht
auf einen Platz im Kindergarten.
So auch Valeria.
Am liebsten war sie auf der Schaukel.
Wegen Corona durften sie die Eltern
aber nicht besuchen.
Deshalb sahen wir Valeria
gar nie live auf der Schaukel.
Wir bekamen Fotos
und konnten so teilhaben.
Jetzt sind wir das erste Mal hier
und sehen die Schaukel.
Es ist sehr emotional
und natürlich auch traurig.
Das ist natürlich traurig.
Aber es ist gut für uns, das sehen
zu können, um abzuschliessen.
Es ist schlimm.
Ich vermisse die Zeit.
Valeria hat in der Schaukel
so gestrahlt.
Sie war glücklich,
ruhig und entspannt.
Im Klassenzimmer zeigt ihnen
Lehrerin Michelle das Lernspielzeug,
das sie extra
für Valeria zusammengestellt haben.
She had her sunshine and her cubby.
And her prints.
Sie kam immer glücklich
von der Schule zurück.
Man merkte, dass sie stolz war,
etwas selber machen zu können.
V.a. zu Beginn,
als sie neu zur Schule ging,
waren wir sehr gespannt,
wie sie nach Hause kommt.
Wenn wir sie anschauten,
hatte sie diesen Gesichtsausdruck,
als wolle sie sagen:
"Wieso macht ihr euch Sorgen?"
"Es geht mir richtig gut
und ich kann das."
Es war jedes Mal wunderschön,
wenn wir sie so
zu Hause empfangen konnten.
Oh, bist du ein süsses Mädchen.
Obwohl Valeria nicht mehr lebt,
werden Mario und Alexandra Schenkel
ihre Kontakte in Boston
weiter pflegen.
Ihre Stiftung,
in die das gesammelte Geld fliesst,
wird die weitere Entwicklung
des Medikaments mitfinanzieren.
Wir hoffen,
sie können Valeriasen ...
... besser machen,
bzw. dass sie genauer wissen,
wie man therapieren muss,
wenn man Valeriasen verabreicht.
Deshalb ist die Hoffnung
immer noch sehr gross,
dass das Medikament in Zukunft
anderen Kindern helfen kann.
Ihr letzter Abschiedsbesuch vor dem
endgültigen Rückflug in die Schweiz
führt sie nach Cape Cod,
etwa 1 Std. ausserhalb von Boston.
* Nachdenkliche Musik *
Hier an der Atlantikküste war auch
einer von Valerias Lieblingsorten.
Sie freute sich immer.
Sie hatte Freude an der Natur
und speziell am Meer.- Ja.
Wir hatten den Eindruck,
dass es ihr an den Tagen am Meer
meistens recht gut ging.
Ja.
Irgendwie wusste sie, dass wir
an diesen Tagen etwas machen,
dass etwas los war.
Dann versuchte sie auch,
so gut sie konnte mitzumachen.
Wir müssen davon ausgehen, dass sie
am Schluss starke Schmerzen hatte.
Daher ist es für sie sicher besser,
dass sie gehen durfte.
Es war auf jeden Fall
eine Erlösung für sie.
Wir sagen uns,
dass sie jetzt keine Krämpfe
und keine Schmerzen mehr hat.
Sie ist jetzt hoffentlich irgendwo,
wo sie ein gesundes Leben hat.
Das tröstet uns - manchmal.
So halbwegs.
Ein weiterer Trost:
Kurz vor Valerias Tod
kam Thierry zur Welt,
ihr kleiner, kerngesunder Bruder.
Zeigen wollen sie ihn nicht.
Ihr weiteres Leben soll privat sein -
ohne Medien.
Wir gehen jetzt weg von dem Ort,
der für uns und Valeria
so wichtig war.
Deshalb müssen wir sie
auch etwas zurücklassen.
Aber wir sind froh und glücklich,
dass wir Thierry haben.
Wir freuen uns sehr über ihn.
Er hilft uns fest,
wenn es darum geht,
mit dem Schwierigen umzugehen.
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
puretype gmbh - 2022